[Music]
good morning my name is Nuno and I'll be
talking about ranking Hotel images using
deep learning so first I'll introduce
Experian the company I work for then
talk a little bit about why we want to
rank Hotel images and then finally talk
a bit about the approach and show some
samples and also some results a little
bit about me so I work for Expedia for
three years run a data science team
there and before that I work in credit
cards for detection also using machine
learning and before that I did an
internship in big data agreements
I also did a PhD in machine learning and
computer science and I actually started
out as a software developer as many of
you probably a little bit about
experience so experi is one of the
largest travel companies in the world
it's about 70 billion in gross bookings
and about nine nine billion in revenue
so if you think about the number of
transactions we have per day that
generates a lot of it that we have a lot
of fun with when you think about
experience actually is not just X become
Expedia is actually a family of other
brands so you probably heard of Auto
comm probably home away or trivago are
also part of the experience family some
of them focus more on online travel with
slides and hotels and car rentals like
experience but some others like
ourselves at home are based only on
hotels and trevallies our meta playing
so of all these brands I work for the
b2b part of the business Expedia
Affiliate Network or Ian at Ian we don't
have a website basically we have an API
that empowers other businesses like
Airlines to add hotels to their flights
when people booked a flight in one of
these Airlines sometimes you are
suggested you also want to look
Hotel and then if you say yes it's
likely that Expedia will be providing
that Patel threw in to in terms of
inventory we give all of our 300,000
ourselves to all of our partners and we
have about seven and a half thousand
partners that we work with so each of
those the separate company an airline or
actually a brick-and-mortar travel
agency that you can see on the street
sometimes and they are being powered by
in you may know a few of the brands so
sweet Airlines Norwegian Airlines
it dreams Arab bookings and many many
more that we can't talk about because
some of our and the work we provide is
white-label so why is it important to
rank images right as humans we are
visual machines it takes us about 1/20
of a second to possess an image or to
recognize someone's face that's four
times faster than blinking an eye if you
think about it's really fast it's just
the way our brain is wired the first
thing we process when you look at
something is the image and if you
transpose that to the tell business when
you're actually looking at the hotel the
first thing you see is the image right
before you even think about price or the
hotel name or anything else your brain
is wired to process the image was you'll
give you that primal instant if you like
it or not straightaway and then after a
few milliseconds you look at the price
and then you look at star rating
TripAdvisor eight and finally you read
the text and that takes a lot along a
lot longer but the first thing is always
the image that's why it is so important
and some images are really good and some
other images are not so good right and
because there are many many hotels and
many many images this is a very hard
problem to tackle for humans right so at
Expedia what's currently happening is
that the feature image or the first
image is manually selected so that one
is generally okay but then all the other
images are either randomly sorted or
they are grouped together for example
the first ten images would be La Vie the
second ten images will be the bedroom
and so forth so especially if you are on
a mobile device where you only have time
or patience to look at three four or
five images right if all of those are
related to the lobby you will just go
and book another hotel or go to a
competitor's site right that's why it's
so important and if you think in terms
of optimization and conversion sometimes
just changing the color of a button can
give you a 1% percent up list in your
revenue or if you want to get a bit more
elaborate and change the sort order of
the hotels you provide the different
customers that can give you a three
percent of leaves so we think changing
something as primal and important as
images will likely provide also a very
good uplift in revenue and conversion so
if this is so important why are we not
doing it right
so there's two main reasons scale and
complexity so in terms of scale we have
10 million images and for that reason is
very difficult to do manually and also
if you think about it you have many
different customer types like a
businessperson may like conference room
image better than a family person family
may actually like swimming pool or
playground area bed so if you multiply
all of those possible combinations by
the 10 million images that you have you
suddenly have a very difficult problem
to do manually right the second reason
we're not doing it is complexity so even
for us as humans to say two things are
similar there's a lot of subjectivity to
that right
similarities subjective and from
machines as you know at least up to five
years ago all images could do in terms
of image processing will be considering
the edges and the shapes using some
thresholded techniques or something a
bit more advanced than that but it was
not very elaborate right so those are
the two main reasons we haven't tackled
this problem before the technology was
just nothing but recently as you know
there have been advances in deep
learning in self-driving cars personal
systems we are all of these exciting
things that already talked during these
three days so it feels like the right
moment to use deep learning to solve
this problem so essentially we focus on
ranking or sorting our images within
each hotel using the learning on our
about 300,000 hotels and then 10 million
images so to do that we follow a
three-step approach essentially so first
is building a data set as you know as
the DES scientist that's often the most
difficult part and what you spend most
of your time after you have a deck set
you're going to train your model and
finally you're going to look at the
results and see how they are so in terms
of data set we actually use the Amazon
Mechanical Turk how many of you are
familiar with and chemical two that's
using essentially is the crowd sourcing
product by Amazon that allows human
workers to essentially do repetitive
tasks for you so what we got from them
was ratings from one to ten for each of
the 100,000 images so this is only a
subset of the ten million all of the
image that we have we gave to the
Mechanical Turk 100,000 images for them
to rate and we got them to rate each
image six times
on average so that means we have about
alpha million human ratings in our data
set
so it's rating is from one to ten and we
also asked the radius to describe what
sort of traveler they are as a business
traveler a luxury travel a family dragon
so in the future when we want to
actually explore the complexity of the
problem to travel type we already have
some of that data in in terms of results
from the Mechanical Turk our average
score is actually 6.5 from one to ten we
declined about five percent of the
ratings because basically they were
cheating or automating the process and
discusses $3,000 so it's fairly cheap to
get 100,000 ratings only by 3,000 loads
and to question a week to get all the
ratings so what's a fairly efficient
process in the end this has some of the
top images according to the Mechanical
Turk writing and these are some of the
bottom images so after you have a
dataset what you do you basically train
a model right way to iterate your
machine learning process to China model
and you divide data set typically into a
train and attach side so what to search
for training and one-third for tasks
essentially the data looks like this so
you have the past URL for the image and
then you actually have the rating for
the image so the rating you have for
each image is average of the six course
you got from the Mechanical Turk after
some cleaning because some of the images
you have very wide distribution so we
sort of clean the data set a little bit
and when in the end you only have one
number per image in terms of modeling we
actually started with the vgg pre
training dataset so most of you who
knows about vgg
so vdg is essentially a model that's pre
trained on imagenet is pre trained on 14
million images and the objective is
basically to classify each image in one
of 1,000 classes so this pre trained
model achieves about ninety two point
five top five accuracy on this data set
and in terms of architecture you
essentially have your convolutional net
layers and then in the end you have your
fully connected players after soft marks
you get the 1000 classes in the end so
you can get this out of the box without
requiring you to do anything and this
model is really good at detecting
objects in images and what you do then
is use a technique called transfer
learning so essentially use your pre
trained model which is really good at
distinguishing between different objects
right and then you take the first part
of your model and then you fine-tune it
on our dataset right so you keep the
first part and then replace the last
part and then you train that on your
date set this actually saves you time
from training everything from scratch
and you also leverage a lot of the
learnings from vgg so in terms of
architecture previously we had the
classifier in the end what we do is
essentially remove that classifier and
replace it by a regression where the
objective is actually to return a number
from 1 to 10 so essentially in the end
in your fully connected layer you have
in the end single neuron with your
prediction there's a few things you need
to change we actually use Kerris to do
this basically you just change the
output layer and we create a generator a
piping generator for the
Russian model because originally you
actually need one folder for each class
so you have 1000 folders so we
essentially change that bit of the code
to use a rating for rating problem where
it's all in one folder and then you have
one file without mappings between the
URLs and the ratings so the model
essentially looks like this you have
your you load your video J model and
then you essentially have two fully
connected layers with some drop out and
in the end we have one Aaron with your
prediction so fairly simple
once you have the model you're going to
train it's a basically compiled it
actually been careless with the
tensorflow back and so it's essentially
compiled it to ten flow and then we just
call fit and this will actually train
them up
so after after you train you can test it
or run it and that's essentially calling
predict and using this model we got the
0.5 mean average error on our dataset on
our test set on a scale of one to ten
and in terms of percentage there's about
a twelve and a half percent error in
terms of the setup using Kerris so as
much as you may know this is a high
level neural network API in python and
we selected the tensorflow
back-end to run it so this allows us to
focus on experimenting and iterating
quickly rather than having to worry
about all the tensorflow detail in terms
of environment to use a eight gigabyte
GPU locally and also some other GPUs on
the on AWS to give us a bit more
fertilization for the test step which is
our main bottom line so there are a few
optimizations that we needed to do what
we found is that the GPU was actually
waiting a lot of time when you look at
the process operating system the GPU is
actually waiting for CPU a lot so
basically create an optimization where I
created a queue to essentially have the
GPU always being consuming things from
from the CPU so basically create multi
thread and multi-threaded that part of
that to go now the interest part
actually we did some data fertilization
because this is our main bottleneck we
have 10 million images that we're taking
like a week to score so this actually
improved to one day
in terms of results so on the left-hand
side or in the right-hand side there's
the existing approach so the top 24
images for this hotel you see the first
image is really good but then you have a
combination of lobby images and then
bedroom images so if you're on a mobile
phone you never go past image for a file
so you'll never see the nice pictures
from the outside then you see the top
images as predicted from our key
planning model on the middle and then
the bottom four pictures as predicted so
it seems to be working fairly well few
more examples so again your lobby your
bedroom and then your exceedance this
hotel has a lot less images than the one
before and then it seems our machine
learning algorithm is doing a lot better
than that so another example this one
there's actually some weird images then
hot by design but it seems to be
captures everywhere which is interesting
so that was it essentially introduced
Xperia motivators the problem and then
explain a bit the approach into some
results because samples if you have any
questions please reach out to me or
friend will actually the live data
scientist in this project and it's also
we're also hiring so if you like to work
on this another cool problem please
reach out
so I'm for Q&A put your hands up if you
have any questions are they I just wanna
say thanks really interesting talk I
think it looks like it shows a lot of
promise I guess I mean the biggest
problem with a lot of you sort of big
machine machine learning style
frameworks is your ground truth and I
was just wondering what you're sort of
feeling was on using Mechanical Turk do
you think there's a sort of a bias in
the type of person that might use
Mechanical Turk as opposed to using
expedient and with that bias the results
are you getting enough maybe maybe
younger people use Mechanical Turk as
opposed to Expedia so I think that's a
really interesting question I think that
there may be some bias we in terms of
where the ratings were coming from most
of them were coming from the US and
India so may you may have some bias on
the cultural aspects of those countries
which may not reflect the the entire
population but so one of the questions
we have how many ratings should we have
for each image and within a few small
experiments and we decided to go with
six but obviously if you have more
ratings that because also be an approach
but yeah I think is a really interesting
point and should be considered in terms
of timeline of the project this is
basically setting us getting us started
and getting a model live on our website
on our wonderful partners websites as we
can AV test and then we need to be able
to look we need to look at actually
what's happening on the partner website
what's happening after customer looks at
the particular image right so when we
have those later we can then close the
loop and make this full process
optimator but these Mechanical Turk
latest attitudes to get us started and
to get that loop essentially ruined
hey thank you for the talk again I would
like to ask at the beginning to describe
the problem that users might be
different like they might have different
tastes and all that kind of stuff but at
the end this wasn't really included in
the model was it No so that's future
work at the minute we have one static
model that will apply to every customer
and then as we iterate on that model and
get the results we will work on that on
that part which should be the most
exciting one
okay just default follow-up what was the
distribution of the customer type so on
the Mechanical Turk when you asked for
the classification what was their
distribution of the answers because I
guess there weren't like many business
customers surprisingly there were a lot
of business travelers and we actually
had nine different categories so a
business family luxury middle class solo
group friends so and we actually limited
the number of categories to three so
that in the initial experiment within
limit and they were like selecting six
or seven different categories so we said
okay each person can only select three
and it's actually fairly well
distributed surprisingly there were a
lot of business travelers in the mix as
long Thanks
thanks to the really really nice talk
could you just say did you did you try
your classifier without the transfer
learning part in what sense so I'm
basically to show you later alone yeah
so we have a sort of a flask up where we
basically inspect our results and in
that app we also have six labels
provided by the classifier and then
overlay that with the final with the
final score
I'll talk one question when you had some
of the images it was showing a nearby
beach something which might not be the
hotel as such how do you make sure they
don't have outliers which misrepresent
the hotels can you repeat the end please
when you have all the pictures some of
them as a nearby beach something was
used in the hotel as such how do you
make sure you don't have outliers which
over-represent on the represent the
hotel in the case or presented give it a
higher rating than it should have had if
you mean because because actually nicest
picture with you I'd not necessarily be
the hotel you could take the average of
all the scores for the pictures nature
didn't have an outlier but how do you
make sure that it is something which is
a good representation of what you are
actually looking at that's a good
question I think is something we work
with still working on when what's under
consideration is should we just choose
our output just be the final score of
the algorithm or should we just or
should we actually limit what goes into
the top five like should we just get top
bedroom the top lobby the top exterior
to sort of guide the ranking a little
bit or should we let just the algorithm
whatever is the first ten images are of
the beach and those are the nice
features just just display those three
still exploring that and as well I think
a lot of those ones will come from AV
testing in the real world there is an
interesting system problem a quick
question here hi thanks for your talk
I'm just interested to know is this
model in production is it integrated
with the Expedia website that we see
today and what is the process of putting
data science in production that you
follow so we're currently testing with
one of our 7,000 partners so this is at
the minute not linked to the main
expedia.com
brand we're actually kicking with this
work of separately on our own brand on
Expedia affiliate and in collaboration
with Auto calm as well so initially
we'll be on a partner so a separate
company that's using our inventory and
then if
we have good results we'll roll it out
to the other brands as well but in terms
of the process we follow is typically we
test on a small subset of traffic and
then depending on the result of the AV
test we roll it out according about the
the business is typically open to those
days oh yeah so here
you said you declined about five percent
of the ratings how did you detect and
determine that what was a pattern there
essentially some of the things we did we
just closes everything to a buy some
notebook
and simplest thing just look at all the
ratings are the same and then locate the
timings between the ratings as well and
also looking at the distribution so it's
not super sophisticated I guess we could
do a bit more work there but we didn't
really see the need at this point
because it didn't see a lot of yeah the
cheetahs were pretty obvious and we
thought the value we would spend in for
example writing some opera detection was
not give enough benefit but it's
something we thought a little bit about
but it's a good good simple questions
the problem you mentioned with the
training being cpu-bound was that a
problem with with the Charis library
itself was it related to streaming the
images off the disk to play it through
the the gradient descent do you know any
more details other I think is generally
with the current data flow
implementation so if you look at the
sort of whole year processes and what
GPU is doing is it idle or is it being
used and at what percentage what we
observed that actually the CPU was 100
percent on the GPU was actually either a
lot of the time so you had to go and
make some modifications to the core yeah
tend to float code yeah so essentially
it's basically just writing a
multi-threaded inversion to not to the
tensile is actually the way we load the
watches right okay yeah so essentially
just just change that weight that loads
the data and multi-thread a little bit
Thanks
thank you for your presentation the
question I have is how were the pictures
collected we're dis sent in by your
clients or did you send people out there
to take them
that'd be difficult but then do your
clients have the ability to improve on
their pictures like they continuously
send in new pictures and they get rated
I guess more automated ly in the future
to improve their profiles so the
pictures actually belong to experience
and they were taken both by yourselves
themselves or by someone working at
experience in the past that went to the
hotels and takes pictures when we
onboard the new hotel that's essentially
how it works in terms of the
collaboration with the partners when we
are able testing something like this
with any of the partners they are
actively involved in that there the fad
can see a question so your partners are
aware that there is value in improving
the pictures and therefore they can
actively actually do that yeah thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]